so what do you think happens come uh
2023 when donald trump uh not even 23
maybe maybe maybe maybe this next year
towards the end of the year trump says i
am officially announcing i am running
lord help us yeah what do you think
these people are just gonna be like you
know what
i've been my whole life let's say let's
say uh donald trump gets elected uh you
know five years ago
uh just about five years ago and you've
got someone who's 15 years old and so
they're growing up in the trump era
hearing nothing in the press but trump
is evil he's a nazi he's a fascist and
must be stopped
a few years goes go by and now they're
19 and they're like i'm going to vote a
lot of young people now these people are
being told and as they're entering their
early to mid-20s donald trump is running
again this is it the end of democracy
whatever
you not only have the entire faction of
antifa
who were college-age kids up to you know
adult men the guy who attacked the ice
facility was in his 40s now you've got
with with another three years another
set of teenagers who are 15 who are
watching all this go down and they're
aging into the fray
more and more ideologues are being
pulled in as we speak and in three years
15 year olds will be 18. they will issue
their votes i think trump's going to
announce you're going to have 16 17 year
olds hearing in the media screeching
louder than you've ever seen especially
as the media is dying out their ratings
are in the gutter they're going to be
like we must embrace this more than
we've ever embraced it and they're going
to get violent add this to the dismal
economic outlook and more people
becoming poorer and more people having
no economic opportunities it's only
going to make the situation that much
worse not just with crime in big urban
areas but
nationally all throughout the united
states the middle america has already
been gutted by big pharma and the opioid
epidemic but i truly believe a lot of
this is orchestrated a lot of this is
planned whether it's done on purpose or
whether it's incentivized by big money
uh for for pure profit reasons i think
it starts on the micro level on the
internet with algorithms amplifying
escalating fights and drama and i think
that's how it started off and i think
it's slowly escalating into this huge
snowball that some people are calling a
civil war some people are calling this
left right divide and conquer scheme uh
i see this done deliberately and as we
fight each other we never truly solve
the problems that are really plaguing us
just two points like like first i'll
i'll i'll bet you a bottle of scotch
that that donald trump doesn't run again
if you want we can talk we can talk
terms afterwards we've talked to some
former staffers who have said you
probably got better information than me
i'm i'm going just on my my my guess on
trump um but more like like i here's
here's the serious thing i i think we
are seeing that we have seen the re the
rebirth of fascism in america like in
america for the first time if you if you
go back and if you read what was
happening in europe in in the 1920s
1930s fascism has finally arrived to the
united states um it's it's existed on
both the the right and the left it's
more ascendant right now in my opinion
on the left and and it frightens me more
frankly um and so yeah like i think in
the near term it's gonna be the the
violence we're seeing is part of that if
you look you know orwell said the word
fascism he's like it's useless because
it's just it's just a slur now it
doesn't we we forgot what the word means
but if you look at what fascism really
meant
um you know for one it it meant this
idea that we were all one that you know
the italian word you know fassi means
it's a bundle of rods and that it's the
the opposite of liberalism which just
says you know you can go your way we're
going to go our way but when you look at
like it's imp implementation
that the fascists were all about
blurring the lines of public and private
life they wanted it
they didn't see a difference if it
didn't serve the the public interest you
know like they had no interest for
private behavior that didn't serve it
that's the democrats so so that's where
we're arriving at that point and it it's
kind of frightening um but we've seen
darker times liberty has seen darker
times fee for example was founded 1946
1946 tate just just pause for a minute
and think what 1946 looked like that the
communists
were a global empire um
like they were they were power hungry
they were going everywhere
we you know our ideas are better we we
we have platforms to share them on um we
need to persuade people don't go down
this road don't go down this road of of
you know toxic ideology where where you
you put where you empower this state to
run your lives in this fashion the
challenge i see is that um you know we
we try to get leftists on the show
periodically but it's it's really hard
but we have had vosh we've had destiny
we've had jen pearlman we've had a
variety of people who are libertarians
many who are hard leftists a few yeah i
mentioned him and uh but mostly we get
libertarians moderates conservatives and
like
i think libertarian is probably the best
way to put it maybe not big l but just
people who are typically like here's the
news i understand what's real
the problem is you know we we do this
show with uh with a variety of voices i
mean luke is very libertarian he doesn't
like to use i don't like that word uh
i'm not saying i'm not saying big all
he's you're a freedom guy yeah he's a
freedom guy and he's ragged on trump the
entirety of trump's uh administration he
was never a trump maga guy the worst
trolling i've ever had on on twitter was
was mega people that took issue with one
of my tweets slamming trump um but you
know like i it's kind of a badge of
honor you got to slam people when
they're wrong i got ruthlessly attacked
by them and it was fine and i welcomed
it and i welcomed the battle of ideas it
freaked me out
that happened to me so here's the issue
the the the the crisis that we're facing
is a crisis of realities two different
universes colliding at least two my my
economic it's funny when people get in
debates on twitter over whether or not
i'm leftist or conservative because all
conservatives are like tim's clearly a
leftist but i agree with the right for
the most part on what's reality so when
they say trump colluded with russia i'm
like well that's clearly false i fact
check it conservatives are like yes
that's correct too because we've also
looked into it but many of these
establishment leftists believe something
nonsensical so what happens is
on this show we just try to be correct
we're not always right we also try to
make sure our labels are correct so i'll
say something like leftists are pro
second amendment that's a fact
liberals are not
but in a lot of a lot of times you hear
the debate it's broken down to the left
hates guns and the right loves guns i'm
like no socialists love guns too karl
marx said you know
under no pretext that famous quote so we
tried we try but we also point out i
think it's fair to say when you follow
the facts you will see the democratic
party is the bastion of fascism today in
america with many republicans as well
the establishment you have the lincoln
project which were these former
republican you know big shots
and they fled to the democrats because
trump barged his way in trump is not a
fascist in my opinion and i think what
trump represented was national populism
which kind of upended the establishment
political parties which which you do
have a tendency towards fascism but then
you end up with many of the leftists
blindly supporting democrats because
they live in different reality
so when you get um australia is a good
example in my feud on twitter with like
claire lehman where i'm like the
guardian has reported this
abc.net.u has reported this and i say
and say hey it's really bad that they're
taking people and putting them in camps
but then you have people who genuinely
believe i made that up
so i went on joe rogan and i remember
seeing uh you know this got posted on
twitter whatever and one of the comments
was i'm 45 minutes in and it's very
obvious this guy tim poole is making all
of this stuff up what
and that's because they live in a
different a totally different reality so
if you believe quillet
and you don't read the news
it's crazy to believe that the the
australian defense force was deployed in
the northern territory and is assisting
with setting up checkpoints and taking
people by army truck indigenous people
to quarantine camps but that's not my
reporting that's the guardian i mean the
guardian is supposed to be some great
outlet well
some people don't live in reality and
because of that they believe things that
aren't true they get angry they get
violent and then they say you're evil
and i'll fight you how do you deal with
that it's not an issue of my policy
positions i'm pro-choice i'm i'm fairly
economically left libertarian but that's
totally meaningless if the actual
progressives don't agree on what is real
like uh we were just looking at
something from kyle kolinsky and we'll
jump into this in a second
where he's claiming dave rubin got some
guy banned on twitter with no evidence
and i'm just like i would never report
that because i would need verifiable
evidence proving that dave rubin
actually sent someone to get someone
banned off the internet but they will
report it as true now certainly we all
have our faults as well we get things
wrong too so i don't want to you know i
i think kalklinski does a good job but
when you have russiagate for years when
you have rachel maddow doubling doubling
doubling down and it's not true
and they still don't let it go after
every bit of evidence proves them wrong
i don't know how you rectify a group of
people who are willing to burn down
buildings kill people while believing
insane stuff like this
how do you solve for that no like it's
the most terrifying part and i don't
know when it started but but we live
today in alternate universes as you say
there's another i'll go back to orwell
he had a great quote um he was i think
he wrote it in the early 40s he was
reflecting on his experience in the in
the spanish civil war and he said
everything since 1936 is propaganda and
he said he the guy with him nodded and
and
and then he explained it he's like look
i i've you know i've from an early age i
saw there was nothing ever written in a
newspaper that was true
he said but you know it was during war
he said where truth completely it was it
was obliterated he didn't use that word
uh but he explained it far more
poetically and when it's one of the
things i thought of like in these recent
years when you're when you're watching a
cnn clip and they're describing a mostly
peaceful protest while well burning
buildings are burning in the background
um
it's troubling when you when you see
this like where where truth is going um
sultan instant talked about the same
thing during war truth dies again i'm
paraphrasing um but you mentioned this i
hadn't thought of this when you said
we're already in a war um i never
thought of it that way but
in in maybe one sense we are and in when
when that is happening truth there's no
place for truth and and people that's
that care about it that actually you
know if you you you tweet something
wrong you go fix it you remove it you
apologize you know when we're in the
business of reporting you get things
wrong and you and you try to you know
you correct it if you do this long
enough you'll make those mistakes what
scares me is we kind of stop doing that
media doesn't go and and fix a lot of
these mistakes anymore they do
occasionally
but um
it is troubling like like
we we live in you know
i'll bring up sults and eastern again
live not by lies and i see lies
everywhere today and and i find it
you know deeply troubling it's one of
the reasons you know you looked at me
you know like as a person that that
might you know say oh it's not so bad i
was more taking issue with the catalyst
of being abortion right i think there is
going to be a catalyst that's going to
cause some some great civil unrest um
you know i just don't think abortion
will probably be the one um you know i'm
not a prepper but at the same time i'm
moving my family to a more safe area
like i'm like yeah i was really close to
that violence in the twin cities last
year was happening i was up at two in
the morning watching all these buildings
burned my family sleeping next to me and
i it was it was really troubling the
preppers are the new prophets in our
modern society and the conspiracy
theorists are the ones who literally
have been calling things as they are
right now uh it's absolutely incredible
they're troubling times but we we can
get it fixed we have the we have the
right ideas we've got to repeal the
truth
i think since september 11th 2001 we
basically it's been a
media manipulation frenzy getting us
into iraq i agree i thought of this
today as i was going through like like
the tsa i took a picture even and i said
you know what bin laden won like like he
he got killed but but you know what
everything he was trying to do like like
like he brought down
you know this evil empire in a way
all the all the values we had kind of
went out the window in 2000 yeah
terrorism won
the u.s allowed itself whether
intentionally or unintentionally allowed
itself to become like a semi-terror it
feels like i'm living under so in a sort
of terror right now so get this
um while you've been talking i've been
trying to pull up this image
that shows the perfect example of the
different realities and uh i can't pull
it off
so i i do have some examples but you can
see this on my instagram oh yeah there's
uh two two uh tv screen two tv screens i
believe it's at a gym on the left it
says sandlin confirms quid pro quo on
the right it says i want nothing sandlin
confirms trump no prid quid pro quo
the the reality is and i wrote about
this was that the truth was there was no
quid pro quo that is not uh so this is a
reference to trump the impeachment
ukraine trial
it was complete fabrication lies from
the establishment and the leftists were
in line with them and they believed
trump did these things and i think a lot
of the democratic socialist types like
the actual core leftists probably it
goes over their head
but in this image i can't even pull it
up anymore i basically say gordon
sandlin said i personally believe there
was a quid pro quo but trump said there
wasn't right and my response is okay
well your opinion on what you think may
have happened is not a fact relevant to
the to the impeachment the the question
is what did trump actually say and trump
said i want nothing no quid pro quo just
you know go and do this and i can't pull
it up sorry this page is not available i
can show you this however
a really good example i wrote same
screen different movie this is a
reference to scott adams quote about
everyone's watching the same screen but
seeing two different things on the left
you have benny johnson who said ted cruz
nukes conspiracy theorist dnc activist
chuck todd chuck ukraine was trying to
get hillary clinton elected which is
what the media wanted ukraine meddling
is inconvenient to for your narrative
dems have no evidence of a crime now
you're working for adam schiff on the
right is john harwood a mainstream media
reporter who said ted cruz disseminating
propaganda fabricated by the kremlin to
weaken the u.s
the reality is
benny johnson a bit hyperbolic but
there's more truth to what he said
politico reported i believe it was in
january of 2017 that um elements in
ukraine high ranking government
officials colluded with uh um uh
the democrats to try and help hillary
clinton to hurt donald trump and it
wasn't like a grand orchestrated
ukrainian government operation it was a
small thing
that's true
politico reported it i mean maybe it's
not true maybe politico made it up you
pick but i can only operate based on
what these news outlets claim is true i
believe that was that may have been ken
delaney who reported i'm not entirely
sure
but for john harwood to come out and say
it was kremlin propaganda when the
reporting was literally politico and the
new york times reported ukrainian court
rules that ukrainians were meddling in
the u.s election i'm like that happened
but what do you end up with they impeach
donald trump on fabricated narratives
now look
you know i like trump at this point i
was like look i'm i'm stopped making me
defend the guy
how are we supposed to reconcile what's
happening when you have people who are
just outright believing made up trash
this guy john harwood literally made
that up i want to say that again john
harwood completely fabricated this
statement disseminating information he
made up in his own mind
and he gets away with it
that uh does confirm everything i know
about hardwood by the way yeah
but so so so
it's two realities you've got the
establishment desperately trying to hold
on for control and maybe they won't they
won't make it maybe they won't be able
to because of the expansion of new
technologies and because you know our
generation is just more social media
savvy young people are not going to be
watching the tv in this way meet the
press is probably going to be worthless
but youtube still props them up puts
them on the front page
so it is we live in an age of propaganda
and and the problem is that would be
difficult that would be a big problem
even if we were a highly educated
society that could you know tell but you
do polling today and you see a majority
of americans can't tell fact from
opinion so
um
this is on multiple fronts um there are
problems and
um you know like i i think you know if
if we're being honest with ourselves
there's going to be a little bit more
pain before things get better
yeah
i think one of the challenges is that uh
have you ever been to northern ireland
no
so i went there and far be it for me to
be an expert but i saw some illusions
that's not illusions allusions to some
of the things we're seeing here and
that's the peace wall
separating the you know the different
sides in the in the fighting that took
place in northern ireland and on one
side they're pro-israel and there's a
bunch of art on you know and on the
other side they're pro-palestine
and i'm like what does that have to do
with your conflict it didn't matter it
was tribalism if one side adopted an
idea the other side adopted the
counterpoint and and that's what i see
here if you have entire generations that
are raised in completely different
realities
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time